yo we are here at the battery right now
we are about to be featuring dr. Aubrey
de Grey we're gonna be talking about
anti-aging or I'm talking about
longevity we got the team here we got
Corrine we got Ronnie we got Al Fredo
Ron hates anti-aging Ron why do you hate
anti-aging it's not that I hate it it's
just I understand and appreciate the
cycle of life yes inclusive of death yes
cycle it's continuous it's not good to
uh it's not good to extend people's
lives especially when we're waiting for
people that are in power making
decisions on our lives when we're
waiting for them to simply die so that
young people can create a better world
for ourselves so uh why do you like why
do you like ages zero to twenty eight
what's the cycles it's the first at 7 14
21 28 it's for carbs that's all that
life is in general if you look at it
logically you know infancy to 7 and then
7 to 14 and then 14 to 21 and then 21 to
28 if you think about the growth in that
period and then at the end of that cycle
28 you're dead and it's just a cyclic
repetitive and slavery if anything else
you we lose the strength of our youth
after 28 so it's gonna extend life they
should consider those four quarters what
if we could extend the feeling of zero
to 28 throughout the rest of our lives
yeah [ __ ] that
boom
always important to hear all
perspectives here's the word we're gonna
have dinner boom the team Tommy what do
you think about anti-aging you gonna
find out tonight
hell yeah high five boom do you want to
live forever I don't think so we do this
is it Liam just this is a vehicle Ron
Vargas is definitely gonna die Allen
socking is gonna die Tommy's gonna die
these bodies are gonna die but who we
truly are and the essence of it all and
that we're figuring out who's gonna me I
saw like Jason Silva like force divine
energy enslaved in a meat puppet for
however long that may be in a far be
degree gets his way
it's forever forever like forever is so
long I mean if you just think about like
the size of the universe right and then
and then think about that in the context
of how long is forever I mean you're
gonna die in an accident you're gonna
die if you know the heat death of the
universe so I think what we're really
talking about is 500 years right people
living 200 years people live 500 years
which is still a tiny little slice of
time but I'd love I'd love to have 200
years there's so many things that I want
to do there's so many places I want to
go and I just don't have time borrowed
time without a doubt only so that I can
share these words with when I should
have been dead these are the
conversations we have here this is our
team the simulation team this is the
battery we're talking to Aubrey about
aging thanks everyone for tuning in to a
little bit of fun pre event from our
team lot of perspectives really
important you guys know it best have a
lot of perspectives differing thoughts
take it all in much love everyone
and tune in to our episode later tonight
peace